MAX SALTONSTALL: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Shield Your
Cloud with Verifiable Advanced
Platform Security,
then stay tuned
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you're like me,
you probably run
a bunch of virtual
machines, and you're
using a mix of your own
hardware, some public clouded
resources, maybe
both, and of course
you want to keep them safe.
But are they safe?
Are you sure?
One major challenge with
this is just how quickly
we see attackers
jump into action
with publicly accessible VMs.
We notice attempts to
penetrate new virtual machines
in under five minutes once
they're publicly exposed.
An attacker wants
to get to your data,
take over your resources,
or even better,
get your credentials,
and then they
can easily do both at once.
To help keep your VM
safe, Google Cloud
provides shielded VMs.
This new option can
protect your resources
and give you assurances that
your virtual machines only run
in a safe, secure,
and expected state.
How does that work?
A shielded VM extends the
defense in depth model
to the very lowest level,
establishing a root of trust
with the boot loader
and the firmware.
This is important because if
you can't trust your OS, then
you can't trust the things
running on top of it--
your intrusion
detection, audit logging,
privileges separation,
or antivirus-- at all.
So the trust needs to start
before the OS even begins,
which is why we need a
hardware root of trust
to keep these fundamental
components safe.
Enter Titan, a chip
designed by Google
to secure the boot process.
Each Titan chip as it gets
made has a machine identity key
burned into it and
can further attest
that it has the correct firmware
running on itself and its host
machine.
Titan also validates
the signature
of the boot loader
and kernel binaries,
so it will stop boot if the
signatures don't check out.
This lets shielded
VMs assure integrity
from the very first
instruction executed.
We go beyond secure boot
and give you measured boot,
providing insight and
control into the entire boot
sequence from firmware to boot
loader to kernel binaries.
Putting all this
together allows you
to validate a virtual
machine as a safe environment
for your data, your
code, and your secrets.
We think everyone
should use shielded VMs.
There's virtually no
performance impact.
They reduce the
trusted compute base.
They fully support live
migration and patching,
and they work
across any hardware.
Thanks for watching.
You can see the full talk
link in the description below.
Subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more Next Rewind
videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]